[Music]
so thank you see the festival has had
conversations about science and religion
over the years perhaps some of you have
come to some of those and oftentimes
there are two sides represented in that
conversation and sometimes the two sides
you know science and religion sometimes
they're contentious sometimes they're
harmonious but tonight we're doing
something differently we really only
have one side here tonight so the group
of people who are gonna come out for
this discussion they're all scientists
they all come from the background of
science but our goal is to see if by
walking this one side this one
trajectory of signs we can gain some
illumination into the other side into
the side of religion the side of faith
so before I bring out our esteemed group
of panelists I just want to set some
context and to do so I'm going to begin
with something which is presumably
familiar to to many of you right so this
is what a beautiful midnight sky
brimming with stars looks like in New
York City now I also have a little cabin
upstate New York in the Catskill
Mountains and when I'm up there and it's
a nice dark night sky I can look up and
see something that looks just like this
maybe not just like this this takes a
Hubble Space Telescope you know but you
get the idea and when you see a wondrous
sky like this you can't help but ask
yourself you know how does it all work
you know how did it all come to be and I
have spent part of my professional life
trying to advance the scientific
understanding of some of these questions
and because I work on the more
mathematical end of physics when I look
up I tend to see order and harmony in a
peculiar language right the language of
mathematics the language of symbols but
many others when they look up at a sky
like this it brings to mind other things
right ideas of of soul of eternity of
divinity of God and for some that kind
of talk it feels kind of low
survey for some it's even off-putting
but when you look at the data you see
something utterly remarkable right here
in the 21st century the modern
technological age and we have long since
cracked the atom explore the surface of
Mars detected gravitational waves and so
much more right there are still many of
us who are believers right so if we look
at some of the numbers about say 2.2
billion of us identify as Christians
about 1.7 billion as Muslims Hindus
Buddhists that gives another two billion
plus if we throw in my little tribe it's
about 14 million right and then if we
add in the atheist this takes us to
one-and-a-half billion which is just to
say there's a lot of people on this
planet who would look to the heavens and
think of heaven
so if aliens right we're able to sweep
down toward planet Earth and let's say
they had some wondrous equipment that
allowed them to detect religious belief
to give us a kind of heat map of faiths
this is what our planet would look like
you can probably work out the color
scheme for yourself
blue as Protestant red as Catholic and
so forth you get the idea we are a
religious planet now personally I am not
religious in any conventional sense but
I do consider myself spiritual and I
certainly do consider myself curious and
one thing that I have certainly got
never more curious about is why do we
believe now the simplest answer is we
have religious beliefs because what
religion tells us is true and that
raises a whole lot of challenges that
we're all familiar with and perhaps the
most relevant for tonight's discussion
is there are over 4000 distinct
religions practiced on earth and if we
just take one of them say we parse
Christianity a little more finely there
are over 33,000 distinct denominations
they can't all be right
so the natural supposition is that at
most one of them is right which would
mean that if Sarah here happy in her own
beliefs right she denies therefore the
beliefs of all others like tarik over
here who again happy in his own faith
denies the validity of all of others and
that goes true for pim and for a frien
and also for Amalia and even holds for
say this guy over here Richard who not
only denies the validity of all other
beliefs he denies ability of all beliefs
so we may be a believing planet but most
of us denied the validity of most
beliefs which means that even if sarah
holds to her religion because it is true
she still needs to explain why everybody
else holds to their own misguided faiths
and that holds true for everybody else
so this takes us to a simple but
remarkable conclusion normally the
discussion of science and religion you
know it all comes down to what's right
what's wrong what's true what's false
but here we see that even if a given
religion is true it hardly changes the
question at all we still need to ask why
it is that so many of us have a tendency
to believe we have to ask yourself what
is it about the human species that
drives us to find order and meaning and
in particular to find the turn toward
the supernatural so utterly natural 1936
this guy over here Albert Einstein wrote
a letter to a school girl named Phyllis
who had asked Einstein about his own
religious beliefs everyone who is
seriously involved in the pursuit of
science becomes convinced that some
Spirit is manifest in the laws of the
universe
Francis is vastly superior to that of
man in this way the pursuit of science
leads to a religious feeling of a
special sort which is surely quite
different from the religiosity of
someone more naive now much has been
made about Einsteins use of this phrase
religious feeling but his
writings made very clear that he was
speaking of an abstract spirituality not
a conventional religion the Word of God
is for me nothing more than the
expression and product of human
weaknesses the Bible a collection of
honorable but still primitive legends
which are nevertheless pretty childish
no interpretation no matter how subtle
can for me change this Charles Darwin
the father of evolution by natural
selection
he allowed for the possibility of God I
have never denied the existence of God I
think the theory of evolution is fully
compatible with faith in God I think the
greatest argument for the existence in
God is the impossibility of
demonstrating and understanding that the
immense universe sublime above all
measure and man with a result of chance
at the same time Darwin also noted that
a religious belief religious sensibility
could emerge from the interplay between
biological and cultural evolution nor
must we overlook the probability of the
constant inculcation in a belief of God
on the minds of children producing so
strong and perhaps an inherited effect
on their brains not yet fully developed
that it would be as difficult for them
to throw off their belief in God as for
a monkey to throw off its instinctive
fear and hatred of a snake the Dalai
Lama has his own iconic perspective on
these issues for Buddhism and modern
science share a deep suspicion of any
notion of absolutes whether
conceptualized as a transcendent being
as an eternal unchanging principle such
as soul or as a fundamental substratum
of reality both Buddhism and science
prefer to account for the evolution and
emergence of the cosmos and life in
terms of the complex interrelations of
the natural laws of cause and effect
from the methodological perspective both
the traditions emphasis
are all of empiricism in the Buddhist
investigation of reality at least in
principle empirical evidence should
triumph over scriptural authority no
matter how deeply venerated a scripture
may be years ago I had the pleasure of
sharing the stage with the Dalai Lama in
an event that took place down in Texas
and I had an opportunity to ask him a
question and the question I asked was I
said look they're all these these books
out there that make the case that what
we're doing in modern physics is somehow
a recapitulation or a reflection of
ideas that ultimately find their origin
in Eastern religious thought I so I
asked him is this true is this your
perspective any very forthrightly said
he said look when it comes to questions
of consciousness that's where we have
something to offer science but he said
when it comes to understanding the
fundamental laws and the particles and
all that detail about how the world
actually works you said we need to look
to science so as a kind of remarkable
moment where this great spiritual leader
showed this remarkable and broad embrace
of science at the same time there are
great scientists who show a similar
embrace of religious thought
here's Nobel laureate William Phillips
the point is that there are plenty of
scientists who see no difficulty in
being serious about their science and
serious about their faith I'm one
example and I know plenty of others and
you've seen the statistics that support
that idea but nevertheless there is a
common misperception in in society that
this isn't the case and here's Francis
Collins head of the National Institutes
of Health I think most people are
actually kind of comfortable with the
idea that science is a reliable way to
learn about nature but it's not the
whole story and there's a place also for
religion for faith for theology for
philosophy
but that harmony perspective doesn't get
as much attention nobody's as interested
in harmony as they are in conflict I'm
afraid 2015 Pew Research Foundation
found that the percent of Americans that
agreed with the statement that science
and religion are often in conflict they
found that agreement with that was
almost sixty percent and that again is
often how the conversation is framed
science versus religion now that is an
important question it may come up here
tonight but it's not the focus of what
we're talking about here tonight instead
we're asking ourselves can we use
science to illuminate religion can we
gain some understanding of why people
have a need to look to a power beyond
themselves beyond the laws of physics is
that need written into our DNA the
natural selection for that kind of
worldview right why in the world does
this world have so many brains that want
to believe that's the question and to
deal with this question try to gain some
insight we have a great group of
thinkers and I'd like to now bring them
out to the stage so our first
participant is professor emeritus from
the College of William & Mary where she
taught anthropology for 28 years
author of numerous books including
personalities on the plate how animals
breathe and evolving God barber King on
the fly our next guest is a research
scientist at NYU Langone Medical Center
he's also professor of cognitive and
affective neuroscience at NYU co-founded
the non-duality Institute where he is
the principal science investigator
please join me in welcoming neuroscience
Zoran Osipovich
also with us tonight is a university
distinguished professor of psychology at
Northeastern University with
appointments at Harvard Medical School
and the Mass General Hospital in
addition to the book how emotions are
maich is published over 100 scholarly
papers please join me in welcoming Lisa
Behrendt
all right finally our guest is the
johnson professor of psychology at
harvard university two-time Pulitzer
Prize finalist and author of the
best-selling books including how the
mind works in the language instinct a
pioneer and champion of evolutionary
psychology named one of Time Magazine's
100 most influential people please
welcome Steven Pinker's alright so we're
gonna have a pretty free-form discussion
here where we're gonna try to address
some of these questions and we're gonna
organize the discussion into three parts
roughly speaking a kind of Trinity of
parts but fitting for tonight's
discussion we're gonna talk about some
of the history of religious belief we're
gonna talk about the longevity the fact
that this is something that has stuck
with us for some time and then we're
going to focus on the benefit if at all
for this kind of way of interacting with
the world and but I'd like to do before
getting started if you don't if you
don't mind especially since it's a nice
small group here it's good to get a
sense of where people are coming from in
this kind of discussion so if we could
just sort of go one by one just sort of
give us a sense of where you know we'll
do it we'll do it if you don't mind and
you don't have to but if you're willing
to share just a couple of words on where
you come from in the religious spectrum
Steven you want to just say a few words
you mean our own believers yeah you
don't mind you don't have to but if you
wanted to well I don't believe in the
existence of supernatural entities so
including God Souls spirits genies
Devils and so on
I am I belong to the same tribe as you
I'm Jewish and appreciate many of the
iconography the traditions the community
of my own and other cultural groups but
that doesn't mean you have to sign on to
the content and I don't write yeah I
would say Steve pretty summed it up
pretty well for me too I we practiced
some rituals in our home as sort of I
don't know not exactly archeological
artifacts but they are kind of artifacts
of the past you know if we decide to
light candles on Friday night I'm using
candlesticks that my great-grandmother
schlepped from Russia and that people
have been doing this you know for over
5,000 years and that's meaningful I also
think that Judaism is an interesting
moral code that is somewhat emphasizes
somewhat more behavior over intent which
is appealing to us in some ways but but
I would say we're colloquially we are
we're atheists as a definitely in our in
our house although we do have trappings
of as I said of ritual in the way that I
described yeah sorry so I was raised as
atheist but like to discover that really
my family were assigned believed in
scientism like science had an answer to
everything
right it was kind of it's a form of
religion I think you know for some
people yeah and so personally I have
practiced meditation for over 35 years
and I'm mostly interested in these
mystical unitary States or non dual
states of consciousness where people
experience both unitary consciousness
either alone or unitary consciousness
with experience and I'm interested what
it does to a person what it does to the
brain right Barbara
growing up in New Jersey I was
as a presbyterian spent a fair amount of
time in church I now identify also as an
atheist when I travel I do find myself
drawn to churches too sitting in the
stillness of a church and to looking at
the art and the architecture I think
that is a beautiful part of our history
but I do that as an atheist and for my
own sense of spirituality I go to a
Springsteen concert so you know there
are there are some curious human
behaviors that strike us as unusual like
I think I don't know how much of this is
true but Beethoven is said to have
always dunked his head in a bucket of
ice water every morning Ben Franklin is
said to have stood naked in front of an
open window every morning Nikola Tesla
you know a great champion and iconic
scientific figure apparently used to
curlers toes a hundred times each night
before going to sleep so you sort of
hear those you raise your eyebrows it's
kind of curious and so on but we don't
feel the need to explain that kind of
behavior but when it comes to a behavior
that is pervasive and that lasts for
thousands of years then it feels like it
deserves an explanation and that's
really why we're having this
conversation here tonight so maybe start
with you Barbara when when I hear the
word faith of religion my mind
automatically goes toward one of the
major religions that are practiced in
the world today is that too limited of
you yeah I think it's a very natural
view but speaking anthropologically if
we were to do that heat-sensing map of
of the world we would see people who not
only believe in God or don't believe in
God but also many many people who
believe in God's plural spirits in the
forest venerate ancestors or have an
enormous range of beliefs so I think
broadening our view to understand that
there's numbers of ways not just in the
past but now to believe is a very
helpful starting point
now you've also done work where you've
gone beyond the species right absolutely
yes my work is in animals and there's a
fascinating conversation going on now
about whether it is reasonable to
suggest that other animals than us do
have a sense of either spirituality or
religious 'ti and there's very
invigorated debate going on you know
Jane Goodall was a very first person to
suggest as far as I'm aware that
chimpanzees may be spiritual but this
has continued over decades this is not
my view I am NOT suggesting that
chimpanzees are spiritual or religious
where I come in is suggesting that their
behavior is an evolutionary platform so
that what we see in our closest living
relatives gives us an understanding of
the building blocks and what later
became our religiosity right so we know
that chimpanzees for example at a
waterfall can show what we might
understand as a sense of awe and wonder
we know that chimpanzees can take the
perspective of another through theory of
mind we know that they can show empathy
compassion that they have their own
rituals and their own rules and so I
think that we wouldn't be where we were
today without our primate past which
includes of course not only living Apes
but what we'll talk about later I
imagine other human ancestors early Homo
sapiens and Neanderthals so just as
culture evolved language evolved and
technology evolved I believe that the
human religious imagination evolved so
Steve you know part of what we're doing
here is trying to think about behavior
and think about evolution in sort of how
they can play off of each other and I
know that the field of evolutionary
psychology is dedicated to trying to
make those kinds of connections precise
can you just give us a sense of what
evolutionary psychology actually does
and how it can give insight into these
kinds of
well the brain like other complex organs
owes it's non-random organization to
natural selection that if there are
circuits in the brain that accomplish
improbable feats then natural selection
is the explanation for how they got
wired up the way they are we're gonna
ask of various psychological at it or
psychological features whether they are
adaptations that is were that whether
they increase the chances of
reproduction in our ancestors and for a
lot of psychological features that's
pretty straightforward to do it's no
mystery why we see in stereo because
it's for many reasons highly adaptive to
get a sense of the third dimension why
we're repulsed by kinds of substances
that are likely to carry disease while
we find certain partners sexually
attractive for religion it's a religious
belief for Supernatural bleep it's not
so obvious and there I don't think there
is any accepted theory that religious
belief per se is an adaptation rather it
can be a byproduct of other adaptations
in particular the ability to attribute
minds to other people
we can't literally get inside people's
heads a mind is invisible colorless
odorless tasteless but we we couldn't
survive as social beings unless we
assume that other people had minds as we
do we interpret their behavior in terms
of their beliefs and desires from there
it may be a short step to attribute
minds to entities that aren't other
human beings such as to trees and rivers
and the wind in which case we call it
animism we attribute minds to in an
identities to our own artifacts in which
we caught in case we call it idolatry or
to know hunk of matter in particular in
which we call it in case we call it
spiritualism disembodied souls and
spirits
and father like entities that don't have
any material existence but have this
thing that we naturally attribute to one
another so it be an extension and one
would then have to explain why the
adaptation of attributing minds to
others sometimes called theory of mind
or mental izing or mind-reading or
intuitive psychology why would she be so
easy to over extend it to entities that
that there aren't and in fact brains and
their part of the answer comes from
experience what kind of input do we have
in living our lives that makes this
belief congenial and a number of
anthropologists have pointed out that
before the advent of modern neuroscience
the idea that minds can exist
independently of brains was not so
far-fetched there's actually some
compelling empirical data Edward Tylor I
think was the originator of this
observation that when we dream for
example it's apparent that some part of
our own part of us is up and about
walking around in the world and our
bodies in bed the whole time so a
natural hypothesis is that our some
locus of experience is not wedded to the
body but can part company from it or in
death if someone suddenly collapses they
may look identical to the way they were
a few minutes ago but something seems to
have left their body that animated it
shortly beforehand and reflections and
still water shadows seem to capture the
essence of a person including their
their activity their expressions their
goal-directed actions and again divorced
from there the actual hunk of flesh that
if you're in a trance from lack of sleep
or a fever or a drug again the
experience is that your mind can part
company
from your body so if you combine those
experiences with our natural habit of
attributing minds it's not far-fetched
to think that their minds can exist
separately from bodies now we know
better we know that the brain can is the
the locus of experience that there are
many ways in which the brain can be
vulnerable to illusions dreaming being
an obvious case there's brain activity
when or asleep and that's why we
experience things but before modern
neuroscience it wasn't such a crazy
belief then one other ingredient is that
we depend for our beliefs on on other
people on experts I believe a lot of
things that I have no basis for
believing in my own experience
yeah like super strength believe in
super I do because because very smart
people tell me that they exist and I
trust it exists they may exist they may
just give some nonzero probability but
that opens up a niche for people to
market all kinds of beliefs about
unobservable entities including gods and
messiahs and and devils and so on and a
whole set of questions which I won't
talk about now is what are the
incentives for the purveyors of
supernatural beliefs what's in it for
them to get other people to believe in
God's and souls and spirits there are
plenty of reasons but that's the other
part of this the overactive assigning of
agency out to the world is better than
an underactive version of it right if
you're walking around and there's you
know a rock and you happen to think that
it has a mind so be it but if you're
walking around and there's a snake and
you don't think it has a mind you don't
think it can attack you that's probably
not a good thing so evolutionary
speaking presumably this overactive
assigning of agency has adaptive value
possibly it's not so clear I mean if it
involves making sacrifices that are
ultimately irrational if it involves
being manipulated by others maybe not
but it may just be that the overall
benefit of being able to attribute Minds
outweighs the costs in Kate in cases
where
others can exploit us in the case of
animals of course animals actually do
have mine so it's not such a crazy thing
and indeed a lot of in some
hunter-gather people's they do attribute
enormous amounts of intentionality to
the animals they hunt and with good
reason because the animals really are
trying to escape them for the same
reason that we try to escape from from
threats and so that degree of extension
is not so far-fetched it's when it comes
to to rocks and rivers and mountains and
trees and wind that it becomes more
problematic
so Lisa what is your view in terms of
are we at some level wired for belief or
is that not an important part of the
equation I think it is actually and I
mean when when we say when you ask are
we wired for beliefs I think that that
can mean a couple of different things
right so in a sense you could say well
all brains actually every brain on this
planet to some extent is wired to make
predictions about what's going to happen
next based on what's happened in the
past
right so brains are not wired to react
to things in the world they are wired to
predict it's metabolically efficient to
predict physiologically most of the
systems that biological systems we have
in the body are predictive to some
extent and so if you mean a lot of
people talk about predictions where when
I say prediction I mean the you know our
brains for example change the firing of
their own neurons in advance of sensory
input arriving to the brain that's how
you're understanding the words that I'm
speaking to you right now you've had a
lifetime of experience of patterns
encoding patterns of what these sounds
refer to and their temporal can the
patterns and their temporal
contingencies so all brains work like
this and if you believe that a
prediction is like a belief which
scientists do write about predictions
this way as if they are beliefs or
explanations that are preemptively
offered to anticipate and explain
incoming sensory inputs then yes we are
wired another way in which were wired
you could say is that but that's for
belief in things presumably that are
demonstrably true
that's belief in in any case right so
you know the idea of that the brain is
wired for prediction as opposed to
reaction is a general explanation it's a
general computational approach to
understanding meaning making of any sort
so that means making meaning of
fluctuating changes in light which you
experience as sights it's vision it's
making meaning of fluctuating changes in
air pressure which you experience as
sounds and it's also making meaning of
changes that happen longer longer
temporal changes sensory changes which
we would think of as an episode or an
event and so and we little infant brains
you know newborn brain a newborn brain
is not like a miniature adult brain it's
not completely its wiring isn't
completely finished and we incur so what
what infants are doing to some extent is
they're waiting for a set of wiring
instructions from the world the brain
expects certain inputs in order for it
to wire itself normally and it wires
itself both to the physical
circumstances it grows up in but also
the social circumstances it grows up in
so we encourage so that's sort of the
normal aspect of brain development
that's related to being wired for belief
but we also wire our children for belief
in other ways we indulge them and in our
culture we indulge them
in believing in animus II of their
blankets and their little cars and their
little toys and some people in this room
might believe that their cars have minds
and right so so we do that's another way
in which brains B can become wired for
belief in the sense of development
actually influences the wiring of the
brain and then there we could also talk
about feelings as the root of belief
that to some extent we feeling is
believing when you believe when you feel
something very strongly you are more
likely to believe it and feeling is at
the core of the wiring of our brains and
really Modar gyu most mammalian brain
some people would like to make that
argument and pull that argument even
earlier I'm going to come back to at a
moment that for Soren you've spent some
time studying the human brain do you
feel that there's evidence that were
there's a internal physiological
predilection for religious belief yeah I
wouldn't so much yes
as much as brain is I think organized to
be conscious it's organized for
spiritual experiences and indirectly for
the Leafs just as Steven Melissa pointed
out I think something happened to us to
our species right we don't know when
maybe you know 3,000 years ago or 5,000
years maybe longer suddenly we became
conscious we became conscious in a very
unique way it's not that just we have
experience whether we have conscious
experience but we know that we're
conscious when we have implicit knowing
that we're conscious and we have an
expression of religiosity going as far
as we we have
you know around 3000 years ago maybe
longer actually but we don't have
records anymore of that that people were
really trying to figure out what is this
thing you know sudden we're conscious
what is it you know who is this person
who is conscious or what is it that
conscious inside us and also what is
this universe the way that peers when we
perceive it with the depth of our
consciousness not just with the surface
of our mind but with the with the
deepest part of ourselves and so that
gives rise to some some very kind of a
deep core sort of explorations in in the
in the nature of human mind that you
know we have records of and when we look
at what I personally feel is sort of the
the innermost core of the religious
practices pretty much in every religious
traditions we find this are these
unitary experiences the experiences of
consciousness itself and they can be
either very deep mental silence in which
all mental processes quiet down and then
there is either just complete blackness
and then within it there is just
awareness consciousness itself doesn't
think doesn't feel doesn't need to do
anything it's just but it's aware and
knows that it's conscious innately
directly doesn't have to think doesn't
have to take itself as an object just
consciousness itself and then that
deepest part of ourselves if it wakes up
suddenly animates within our experience
the quality of our experience changes
dramatically right from this ordinary
experience where I am over here I am
limited to my body I'm limited to the
surface of my skin whatever my mind has
constructed and learned over the course
of my life who I am what the world is
how the two relate to each other how I
relate to others so we have this
elaborate self world model inside our
head that filters everything you
experience
that takes a break temporarily however
briefly and suddenly we experience that
everything is one reality one
interdependent but also at the same time
one consciousness that seems to extend
that's the experience and encompasses
everything and I think that religiosity
try to capture like what this is if when
the theistic religion says that God is
simultaneously transcendent and imminent
in all things so in all things in this
experience here that we're having right
now sitting in this wonderful place this
is the experience of God being
transgender and imminent at the same
time that is one way of saying it right
I didn't look at it that way but that's
right so another way to say it is that
we have a two sides to our consciousness
one side is a mind that creates
experience the other side is awareness
which is just like a mirror and it
simply register what is happening
without doing anything to it
and the two are different in this view
they're separated by this substrate
which is kind of like an unconscious
film matrix no it actually exists in the
universe States they say you know I
don't but what was that what interesting
what happens is when mind wants to find
what what consciousness is it just finds
itself it finds attention and finds
intelligence and it finds vigilance but
it it can't panic if it doesn't know how
it can penetrate through this
unconscious substrate and then it's
basically conclude there is no
consciousness right there's not it's
just a mental processes right and from
the side of awareness what the substrate
does is the wareness can't recognize
itself it can't recognize what it is
directly so it experiences itself as a
subject who is having experience and so
from that perspective spirituality and
spiritual beliefs our consciousness
trying to find itself it's trying to
figure out what it is so so Barbara can
you take us back to the the earliest
evidence
have for that kind of internal
self-reflection that ultimately we think
may have been the seeds for religiosity
well the first thing I'd like to start
and say is that yes it's certainly true
that we attribute intentionality to a
lot of animals but the fact also is that
they are intentional yeah so we
certainly don't have corner on the
market of intentionality or
consciousness or sentience or any of
these other things but if we're going to
talk about the human evolutionary
trajectory we know that our species is
about two hundred thousand years old our
genus is around 2.4 million years old so
the question becomes when do we start
seeing any of these symptoms if you will
and it's very interesting that there's a
cave in South Africa rising star cave
that is the home of this human perhaps
ancestor but hominid in any case called
home onda lady and apparently there were
numbers of individuals who were
literally dragged by others into a very
deep subterranean chamber in this cave
so rising star is a very famous project
in paleoanthropology and one can watch
often live feeds of the scientists
trying to study these chambers and they
have to crawl through these incredibly
small passageways and yet we know that
at approximately 250,000 years ago
people were disposing of their dead in
very intentional ritual ways going
through a lot of effort and a lot of
energy to do this now the problem
becomes now that is that controversial
or is that they're bringing the people
to the chamber is not particularly
controversial right the whether it was a
ritual burial exactly the next step is
controversial because of course we have
the small problem which is that you know
belief doesn't fossilize so we don't
know right and we
have people we have a chamber and we
have our minds and as we're talking
about right we're searching and yearning
always to figure this out is it the case
though that it's the people of was
anthropologist have already discovered
let's say homo Neanderthal is skeletons
that are Poe you know they've been
buried and posed in a particular way
with things around them and so like I'm
soon Gere right but right but we're
going in a kind of order so I'm starting
a little earlier that's right we have
the roots of Neanderthal populations at
this time but what's so fascinating is
that the Neanderthal burials don't come
to a hundred thousand years ago or sixty
thousand years ago in some gear in
Russia which is a homo sapien site and
we just mentioned there's like twenty
seven thousand so my idea is that again
we have some glimmers and some
intriguing hints two hundred and fifty
thousand years ago now let's just fast
forward let me leap over many thousands
of years we've come to Neanderthals they
are not our ancestors they are our
cousins we used to say that they lived
from two hundred something thousand to
forty thousand and then they went
extinct we no longer say that because
here in the audience there's tons of
Neanderthal genetic material in many
populations except some populations in
Africa because we did not have
Neanderthals in Africa we find just as
you were saying Lisa that there are very
intentional burials with all kinds of
grave goods so people didn't just you
know stick people in the earth they
marked the graves as something special
to give you one example there's a forty
thousand year old burial of a toddler in
what's today Spain with a hearth all
around sixty sets of Oryx and bison
horns are rhinos skull this was a place
that mattered in some sense we can think
of it as a sacred place the question is
is there belief in an afterlife is their
belief in supernatural beings how would
we know we're imposing a great deal of
our framework on to the past keep going
in time we come to cave art and of
course we're familiar with the cave
paintings these are not only Earl
Homo sapiens but also in some cases
Neanderthals we do know that now this is
a relatively recent discovery that we
are not the only cave painters but
what's fascinating for me about this is
you have these glorious depictions of
animals that these people hunted but in
addition to that some very mystical and
fantastic figures a bird headed man in
Lascaux cave in France a human that is
part bison some other just wild figures
so this is not just people representing
the reality they saw before them but
rather there's an interest in what is
not in front of you what is not just
here and now we fast forward one more
time we go to Turkey to this particular
perhaps temple gobekli tepe
is dated to that period on a hill in
Turkey massive 50 ton blocks that people
moved onto a hillside and carved with
again elaborate largely animal images we
think this is a ritual space not
everyone agrees this is contentious but
on every single case there is a good
argument to be made for the possibility
of the human brain uncoupling itself
from the here and now to think about
these questions of the supernatural and
we have hints we have to go forward in
time again before we come to a really
institutionalized religious system but
again the reason that I think the human
religious imagination evolved is because
of all these earlier cues right right
and I think that Barbara's bringing up
something really important and that is
your where we're all talking we're sort
of fluidly talking back and forth as if
spirituality and religiosity are
identical forms of meaning making and
they're really not there are many many
ways to be spiritual some involve belief
in a supernatural deity with agency but
not all of them do right some of them
sometimes spirituality means just being
full of awe and wonder at something
larger than you that trends
it's self-transcendence like I'm
connecting with nature for example
Einstein was saying in is exactly and I
think one so one way to think about this
is that when we're talking about the
evolution of religious thought or
spiritual thought or we're talking about
the biology of spiritual thought we have
to be thinking about the fact that we're
talking about different psychological
features here one has to do with you
know connecting to something in the
moment that's bigger than you and that
might transcend you one element or
feature is about explanation right and
another is about agency and so those may
not have all evolved at the same time or
perhaps they're not all meaningful for
all people so everyone in this room has
had a spiritual experience they might
not call it that but they've had a
experience where they've connected to
something that's bigger than themselves
that leaves them feeling awestruck but
not everyone would take the additional
steps of trying to find an explanation
in that or trying to find agency in that
or and so but if we do go and focus on
beliefs that do transcend just a sense
that there's a larger reality that
you're a part of and goes toward a
supernatural beliefs and things that
science typically would not confirm do
you see the potential for an adaptive
value for a progression that would lead
to a brain that would have a tendency to
do that it's hard to give an adaptive
explanation for belief in entities that
don't exist there there can be an
adaptive explanation for the search for
explanations which obviously can't are
not infallible and that can be misled by
by
absence of evidence by people who have
an interest in in promulgating certain
explanations so I think you have to
direct the question at not the content
of beliefs that that we associate with
particular religions but just in
particular ways of thinking but ways of
interpreting the world ways of in which
influences which people influence the
beliefs of one another what are the
kinds of things that we can hypothesis
hypothesize and then what does that
leave us vulnerable to hypothesizing
which from the perspective of science we
know may be incorrect but can
nonetheless be very seductive to a mind
that is apt to think in certain
directions so what's your view say of
those who've made the case that the
adaptive value is not so much in the
actual belief in things that perhaps
don't exist but it is from the cohesion
the group cohesion that that can yield
if there are many people for whom that
belief is shared then all of a sudden
you've got a stronger group bonding does
that does that hold any weight for you
at all there's there's a you know I
think there is a kind of folk theory of
evolution that the that adaptations are
all for group cohesion because whenever
there is some mysterious aspect of
groups of human psychology for which
it's not clear what the the adaptive
value is people will say well it fosters
group cohesion why Dury into a music
group cohesion why do we dance group
cohesion right but there are a couple of
things wrong with that style of
explanation I'm very deeply suspicious
all right the explanation always says
group core one of them is group cohesion
is not in fact the what what natural
selection selects for it selects for
propagation of genes sometimes groups
cohesive groups can help the individuals
that compose those groups but if a group
is too cohesive you can you could be
exploited by the group you could be
cannon fodder you could be a sacrificial
victim for the benefit for the cohesion
of the group but any gene that would
allow you to be
exploited by the group would be select
selected outcasts genes are selected
much more quickly than than than groups
also it's I think it's too easy to use
our own intuition that we like to bond
over music over religion and so on but
that is itself a part of our psychology
that needs an explanation why would
beliefs in invisible entities Minka
group go here more data that you can't
take that for granted that's as much of
a puzzle to a psychologist as but you
see we do see evidence of that even
though we may need to explain it we do
although I mean but the supernatural
beliefs can also divide a group needless
to say there are Wars of Religion and
precisely because they the content of
those beliefs can't aren't derived from
shared experience they're not things
that everyone can just open their eyes
and see their thinks you have to be told
and that means that if you're told by
different famines or different priests
or Imams and you can go to war over
those beliefs so that's why I think the
group cohesion doesn't strike me as a
satisfying explanation do you have a
different view I have yes I think I have
a different view or maybe I want to add
some information to contentious you
can't leave me I have no problem with
being contentious anyone who knows me
knows what's true and but use here's
what I want to say that I think I think
that there there is an immediate
advantage potentially which which is
there are two that I can think of that
that relate to the functioning of a
nervous system in the following way
first of all uncertainty is tremendously
stressful for a human nervous system and
I don't mean stress in a euphemistic way
I mean it in a it adds a metabolic
burden to a nervous system which if it
persists can actually make someone sick
and I think religious beliefs can reduce
uncertainty it can explain they
sometimes explain the unexplainable this
is you know some things that we now
might explain through science used to be
thought of as magic where as the caused
by deity so I think in some ways it is
not just psychologically comforting it's
actually physiologically potentially
less it reduces of people's stress it
reduces their what scientists would call
a low static burden so very simply just
you know to step back one minute and say
partly our brains evolved not to think
and see and feel but in order to
regulate the systems of our body as our
bodies got more complex brains got
bigger a brains main job is to keep the
systems of your body alive and well so
that you can propagate and propagate
your genes to the next stage let me let
me just finish you and and I'm at yeah I
know you're gonna disagree but and you
know your brain is constantly running a
budget for the the resources in your
body and it's not budgeting money it's
budgeting glucose and salt and so on and
so forth and so if you think about your
brain running a budget for your body
uncertainty just drains that budget it
drains that budget much faster and makes
it really harder for people and there's
also I think a social aspect to this too
in the sense that we are social animals
we evolved to be social animals is one
of our major adaptive advantages to be
social animals but what that means is
that we regulate each other's nervous
systems we don't bear that body budget
on our own we have other people to help
us do it and you know there are other
social species right so insects are
social and they regulate each other's
nervous systems through chemicals
through scent and
and some mammals add you know touch and
they might add hearing and primates add
vision and we as primates have all of
those ways to regulate each other plus
we have ideas that we share and so there
are many ways in which religious belief
can actually reduce the metabolic burden
data for that I mean is there data that
really it makes a convincing argument
that where's this belief does for do
there actually is I mean I'm not
advocating this I'm just saying as a
scientist there is data there are data
to show that people who and and I'm I
want to say this you know I'm not
negating any of the the challenges or
problems that religious belief
introduces to a fitness argument I'm
just saying that there is this other
side where there are data to show that
people who are religious actually are
somewhat happier and healthier and have
greater well-being but that's because of
course they're living amongst other
people who believe what they believe
right Steve you had a responsive and
Barbara yeah
yeah make the point that you know we
we're actually operating in a framework
of human exceptionalism when we keep
asking things like was social cohesion
you know part of the reason that that we
were religious or did being religious
drive social cohesion because you know
why are we not asking about orcas for
example orcas are exquisitely cohesive
and they do things as a group and they
regulate each other as individuals and
they solve their problems as a group and
they manage to do that without God and
chimpanzees managed to do this without
God so I think that in addition to the
problems that Stephen pointed out with
social cohesion arguments that this
they're thrown out constantly
that you know we can just look at the
natural world and we can see that there
are so many different pathways for this
if we only look at our species and we
don't take this comparative approach
we're not going to get answers to these
questions we say I agree that religious
belief can reduce stress but I don't
think that that can be an explanation as
to why it's adaptive because the fact
that uncertainty leads to stress is
itself an adaptation namely there were
missing some information that's critical
to our well-being and we're when when we
get stressed to nervous that motivates
us to seek out that information or to
act in a way that is keeps us safe even
the state of ignorance but there can't
be an adaptation to do stress by false
certainty that is by being certain about
something some claim about the world
that it in fact is is not true because
if I'm really nervous
say because there's a I think it may be
a predator and someone convinces me no
it's actually a rabbit appearing in the
guise of a of a predatory cat that might
reduce my stress but it's not an
adaptation so Barbara you gave us some
history of where you think this may have
begun all the way back in in human
history what's your sense of why it has
persisted for so long now I tend to come
back to this issue of community and
prayer
dis because I think if we shift the
perspective from looking so much at
belief and sacred texts which we tend to
do in today's world you know you put up
a slide that talked about the percentage
of the pie in terms of Christianity and
Islam and and that that's one important
aspect of this but I think that for many
of the world's people there is just
something that's irreplaceable about
that sense of community that sense of
ritual practice and that sense of
familiarity and it is sure it's possible
to try to replace that with some other
ways to find those same things but there
is something about the connectivity that
comes through the transcendence that I
think is important when you bring those
two elements together the community Emma
transcends is in sharing that emotional
meaning making and one of the things
that I like very much about the people
who are discussing whether there's faith
and other animals is the idea of
breaking the link between making
religion always be about text and belief
so I think that that that helps us
understand this question a little bit
the idea you know I think about what
Martin Buber wrote becoming from the
tradition of Judaism and he wrote that
all real life is encounter and there's
something that's particularly
transporting about sharing encounters of
transcendence and I really feel that it
has something to do with the persistence
that we see but clearly when we talk
about the spirituality instinct that's a
very fraught term because of the
secularization that's happening in the
world if that really were to be
considered an instinct how do we explain
the tremendous transformation that that
is that we're undergoing so people are
finding humanism communities other
communities with a different type of
transcendent connection so I think
there's a balance between what continues
as very very strong tradition that
carries communities forward together
with new ways of imagining some of these
very same things that are coming about I
mean the ways that people can experience
religion now I mean they extend into
communities with AI they extend to
virtual reality is virtual churches
virtual connection virtual mosques but
also the
idea that we're beginning to think you
know just differently about animals in
nature I mean we know Emily Dickinson's
church right well we also know that one
of the beauties of the evolutionary
perspective among many others is not
only understanding our own place in the
world but our really deep sharing with
other animals and so I think there's the
possibility that we are going to
continue this shift of finding different
ways of sharing transcendence as I feel
with nature with animals
so does that transcendence relate to I
mean Stephen Jay Gould I believe once
said that all religions begin with an
awareness of death
so is that transcendence profoundly
connected with death or is it somehow
independent of it I think you've hit on
an important thing part of my last six
years of my work has been very
profoundly taken up with a question of
animal grief an animal mourning and I'm
not suggesting again to be very clear
that animals have some kind of sacred
sense of death but they have a deep
awareness of loss so that we find over
and over again not just you can't give
an example I mean that yeah I can't give
loads of examples but for example with
elephants we know that the entire
community responds if a matriarch dies
there was one particular example in
Africa particularly community of
scientists who followed for seven days a
parade of mourners who came to this
particular matriarch who had died her
name was Eleanor and not only her family
but matriarch of other families some
stood vigil over the body some rocked
over the body others showed distress so
my definition of animal grief involves
some kind of symptom of distress social
withdrawal failure to eat failure to
sleep some vocalizations but it's not
only the what I call the usual suspects
the big-brained mammals like chimpanzees
cetaceans and elephants where we see
this my research is showing that we find
it in animals as different as colored
peccaries in Arizona chickens all sorts
of domestic animals the animals that we
live with and again what I think is so
important
about this is not necessarily that the
animals have the same awareness of death
that we have but that they feel this
profound sense of loss that is emotional
meaning making and that's where they
enter into this community of sort of a
transcendent experience in a in an
animal sort of way that I think is the
foundation for this discussion so Steve
let me ask you so transcendent
experience community is one powerful way
of thinking about what religion provides
on the other side of the discussion
you've got people like Dan Dennett
you've got people like Pascal Boyer and
and various others whose explanation
tends more toward a mechanism the
spreading of ideas the spreading of
memes you know an idea jumps from brain
to brain to brain and it naturally
tickles certain receptors that we are
naturally attuned to and therefore
certain ideas have a tendency to stick
and spread among them being the very
ideas that constitute religious belief
is that a an approach that you think
gives us insight or is that not
yes--we thinking about because what
we're what puzzles us when we try to
explain the prevalence of religious
belief is not so much why people more
than debt and the dead feel a sense of
loss feel that profoundly effects their
lives because it does profoundly affect
their lives it ought to if you if you
didn't mourn someone when they were dead
if you when they died how could you have
loved them when they were alive I mean
it's that that is in a sense an easier
set of reactions to explained what
puzzles about about which is a belief in
the in the Trinity and in Hell and in
you know 72 virgins and and all of the
other content folk beliefs that go well
beyond a sense of awe at the immensity
of the cosmos or loss of the sense of
death
that's where Pascal boy a and
dan Sperber and others gonna step into
why we're vulnerable to such specific
beliefs as opposed to emotional
reactions to major events that affect us
and their I should actually credit
Pascal boy for for linking the idea that
we are mentalizing creatures were apt to
attribute minds to others as a one of
the core explanations for why we are
subject to religious belief so these de
spiritualist beliefs right so Lisa
what's your view on sort of these these
two sort of polls no the the need for
community transcendent experience and
perhaps something that just speaks to
the way in which certain ideas naturally
stick inside a brain that evolved to
perform certain tasks and survive I
think that I think that both of those
explanations to some extent or phenomena
I'm not really sure if you're referring
to them as explanations or just
phenomena are actually rooted and the
are sociality is a species so i think
you know it's not a metaphor to say that
we that we regulate each other we do in
in very substantial ways and in ways
that we're completely unaware of and
part of how we do this is we create
meaning for we create meaning that is
shared and realities that emerge only by
virtue of collective agreement so what I
mean what I mean by that is so we're you
know we're talking here for example
about grief and that animals non-human
animals feel grief and and so on
non-human animals feel loss for sure
I think there's no question that that's
the case and they suffer I think there's
no question that's the case but research
on emotion suggests pretty clearly that
there is no inherent emotional meaning
in any set of physical signals that
occur from your body what we do is
humans is we learn to impose meanings on
those signals right so a scowling face
for example is not a universal display
of anger people only scowl about 25
percent of the time when they're angry
and they scowl at many other times when
they're not and there are many cultures
around the world including
hunter-gatherers who don't recognize a
scowl as anger for example but in in
many cultures and it's an interesting
question about why this is the case but
we'll just hold that aside for a moment
well what we what we do is we impose
meaning on a scowling face we impose
meaning on a scowl and by virtue of that
meaning that we've imposed the scowl
actually taken literally takes on that
meaning and can predict what's you know
we can easily predict what's going to
happen next
so what I mean by this is it sort of
works in the same way as money works
right there's no inherent nothing that's
ever served it is human as currency in
human cultures does so by virtue of its
physical nature alone what happens is a
group of humans impose a meaning on
pieces of paper or little rocks or salt
or barley or big rocks in the ocean that
can't be moved or mortgages or you know
any number of things and all of a sudden
those things literally take on value
they can be traded for material goods
only because we all agree that they can
and when someone removes their agreement
when people you know withdraw some
number of people withdraw their
agreement those things no longer have
value
well emotions are kind of built in the
same way heartbeats chained your heart
rates change faces move
distress can occur out of loss when you
lose someone who helps to regulate your
body budget and you lose that person you
feel like you've a lot of lost a part of
yourself because sort of you have
actually lost someone who's helped to
regulate you know your nervous system
and we impose meaning on those physical
events that that take on that meaning I
mean they take the the physical events
take on those meanings by virtue of the
fact that we as a culture agree that
that's the case and so I think that that
in my view this is partly why memes
occur because they are ideas are
contagious in a sense because we often
as a you know part of our one of our
sort of super powers as a species is the
ability to create meaning like the
ability to create something real where
there used to be nothing real only by
virtue of you know collective agreement
we impose meaning on something physical
and then that physical thing takes on a
bigger meaning and to some extent I
think we also do this with what we think
of as transcendent experiences so when a
group of people are all together having
a similar experience at being you know
awestruck or wonderstruck at something
in nature there's a an opportunity for
you know creating social reality for
creating a meaning that wasn't there
before that supercedes just a shared you
know wonder of the moment and and so I
don't see these as these ends as really
different I see them as kind of emerging
out of the same capacities so in the
remaining time
maybe we can just focus on humans and on
on religious belief and and maybe we
could start with you Barbara you know
there's been a view that that's been
around for a long time that as science
progresses it kind of pushes out the
need for religion in terms of its
explanatory capacities and so forth now
what suggested over time that the role
of religion would decrease do you do you
imagine that that is the pattern that
will play out or is that a completely
wrong and oblique way of thinking about
the role of religion and therefore what
its future will be yeah it's interesting
I feel two things at the same time I do
think that the increasing tendency
towards humanism and secularization is a
very welcome thing I mean I did say that
I am here as speaking as an atheist as a
person who was a non-believer we
certainly want to be able to think
clearly about science and about the
forces that act in this world and we
know all of us know that religion is not
always helpful in that particular way at
the same time I think it's really
important to think again about the cross
cultural patterns and the number of
people in the world who don't fall into
believing in big sky gods who don't even
in some cases have a word for religion
and I'm not suggesting that that makes
them different in any kind of you know
scale of intelligence not at all we know
that all human populations have the same
capacities but sometimes just being
religious is just the way life is it's
so much a part of the air the of the way
that you live that it's not something
that is going to change so that I think
these are two different ways of looking
at it and I'm not sure how to weigh them
and I'd be interested to hear what other
people would say about yeah why don't we
go write down lines Orin do you have any
so I think that at its best it gives us
a framework right to experience the
spirituality to be able to connect to
something that's larger than the
and so if it it fulfills that are all
for people I think then that's yeah you
know that is its purpose I hope that you
know as the ages ago the science and
spirituality basically flowed through
each other you know smoothly and I think
that for that really we just need more
research in these topics these are
thoughts on the future I think I've made
it I think I would stand by my
descriptions I think that there are some
advantages to religious belief but I
think there are also some major major
disadvantages some of which Steve is
talked about and I I think it from my
perspective it's probably about time to
wonder whether or not the disadvantage
is outweigh the advantages frankly and
because there are other meaning-making
systems that are available to humans to
help them make sense of the world some
of which may not have the disadvantages
they may have the advantages of
religious belief but they might not also
have the disadvantages and I so I
probably lean more in the direction of
wondering how it would be possible to to
test that you know to to investigate
that deep thoughts on that yeah several
trends and the overall historical
archive religious belief when is a lot
of religions have become more humanistic
they don't take them that literal
beliefs as seriously as they used to if
you're a really believing Christian and
that if you don't accept Jesus then
you're gonna go to hell then you really
ought to try to convert people with
swordpoint and you really ought to slay
heretics you'd be doing it's like a
great public health measure your saving
eternity of suffering in hell for
billions of people but most Christians
no matter how serious they take their
belief don't try to convert people at
sword point anymore they don't have
inquisitions and they're not completely
consistent and that that
there's a kind of benign hypocrisy among
many believers that they fortunately
don't act on the totality of their
religious beliefs and that's been a very
beneficial trend the institution's
persist this the all-encompassing nature
and the beliefs get diluted another is
that in when people switched their
religious affiliations the overwhelming
tendency is toward no religion at all so
the world is becoming less religious
there are two reasons why that may seem
hard to believe one of them is that
religious people have more babies and so
the number of religious people is
actually increasing or and projected to
increase even as the number of people
who switch our switch in the direction
of no religion the other is that
religious groups tend to be that more
politically organized so the problem
with secularists and humanists and
so-called nuns and o-n-e
not in UN that is people with no
religion is they don't vote evangelicals
all vote well I shouldn't say all some
of the 80% of evangelicals about 25% of
the unjust the unaffiliated vote and so
there's a an outsized influence of
religion in politics because of this or
organization so our perception of the
growing influence of religion is in a
not exactly an illusion but it is pushed
along by the greater fecundity and
greater political organization of the
religious even as the overall direction
is away from religious belief with
secularization including the United
States which was a long for a long time
was an outlier that every other Western
democracy had become less religious in
the United States it stayed constant the
United States is now moving in that
direction as well so one final question
which is sort of the inverse of the
topic that took up some of our time and
thinking about animals and their
reactions and beliefs what if we flip it
the other way so you know a hundred
years from now or five hundred years
from now we get visited by an alien
civilization
and we show them what we've learned in
math and physics and they nod their
tentacles and you know they you know
we're all sort of good but then we show
them our religious beliefs do you think
that they'll look at that and say yeah
yeah we got it you know we've got our
Jesus - and and or or or will they be
completely baffled as to what this thing
called religion is Barbara thoughts on
that wild speculation I have no idea the
answer to that question - if I had to
guess yeah
I would guess baffled I think that if we
think about how five hundred years ago
we didn't know much about
electromagnetism right and now we can do
all kinds of things with it and we can
actually entertain ourselves with it
well think of the deal aliens come and
they understand the function of
consciousness in the universe right and
they can use consciousness that we use
automatisms
for all kinds of things it's not any
kind of a mysterious thing for them yeah
that's a thing where it's going they
said I don't think they'll be baffled
and I don't think that they'll
necessarily share you know I I mean I'm
just I'm not even speculating I'm
imagining I think that they will see it
as you know part of the evolutionary
trajectory of evolutionary development
of a species and you know maybe
something that was a necessary step
along the way but it became unnecessary
at a certain point final cloth on that
Wednesday yeah I tend to agree that it
may be similar to our attitudes towards
the animistic beliefs of people that
we've come to come across that we can
their in intelligible but but we might
consider them ops a week and do you
think that they will have had a similar
evolutionary trajectory and neither is
this an intrinsic part of the way in
which a living system would evolve that
can survive that it will necessarily
ascribe agency in the world and tell
stories about what those agents do and
the role that they play or is this some
peculiar thing that happened to the
human species great a great question a
profound one but I suspect that I guess
the question is just sociality depend on
reciprocal mentalizing attributing
complexity to to other creatures or yeah
I suspect it does but it's just a
speculation if so would there be enough
evidence early enough in the history of
an intelligent species that it would not
be tempted by over attribution of a
mental of cognitive organization to
entities that may not actually have it
very good so one day we may find the
answer to that question but until that
time please join me in thanking the
group here
you
[Music]